J'ai mal à la gorge, mais en plus,
ça fait deux ou trois jours que ça dure
et je vais prendre
rendez-vous chez mon médecin.
Alors adresse email, prénom,
nom, numéro de téléphone.
Mais pourquoi il demande tout ça ?
C'est vraiment nécessaire ?!
C'est une bonne question,
mais faut pas que ça te rende malade.
Allez, on va essayer
de comprendre tout ça.
Rendez-vous dans mon cabinet.
Enfin, je veux dire dans mon atelier.
Toutes ces questions que l'on me pose
et les renseignements que je donne
sur mon identité, civilité, adresse,
date de naissance... sont souvent nécessaires
pour créer un compte
et accéder aux services
d'un site Internet ou d'une application.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
les données personnelles.
Et c'est grave docteur ? En soit, non.
Tout dépend comment cela est fait
et de quelles données on parle.
Pour le moment, on parle de
données personnelles.
On reviendra sur les données de santé
un peu plus tard.
Même si cela paraît anodin,
l'ensemble de ces données personnelles
en disent beaucoup sur nous,
parfois plus qu'on ne l'imagine.
Lorsque vous donnez votre adresse,
on peut en déduire le quartier
dans lequel vous vivez.
Les endroits que vous fréquentez
à proximité de votre domicile.
Les commerces, les lieux de loisirs,
votre niveau de vie. Et ces informations
constituent une source de renseignements
très utile pour certaines entreprises.
En récupérant vos
données quand vous surfez sur leur site,
elles peuvent vous adresser
des publicités ciblées
concernant des produits
plus adaptés à vos besoins.
Si vous habitez en Bretagne,
dans une maison, par exemple,
on aura plutôt tendance à vous proposer
des produits liés à l'activité
nautique ou au jardinage. Des palmes,
une tondeuse , un longboard...
Un internaute qui lui a élu
domicile dans les Alpes
recevra davantage de publicités
liées à la randonnée ou au ski.
Une fois qu'elles ont collecté
ces informations avec votre accord,
certaines entreprises peuvent tout à fait
légalement les revendre à d'autres
qui pourront elles aussi
vous faire des offres personnalisées
et ainsi de suite.
Raison de plus pour faire
très attention où vous cliquez
et ce que vous autorisez ou non.
Mais je ne comprends pas.
Il y a plein d'infos
que je ne pensais pas fournir.
Comment savent-ils tout ça?
Et comment font-ils pour les récolter?
Eh bien, grâce aux
fameux cookies notamment.
Je mange jamais de cookie moi,
je préfère les madeleines.
Mais non, je ne parle pas de ces cookies.
Un cookie informatique,
c'est un fichier texte qui s'enregistre
dans le navigateur de votre ordinateur.
Il est généré par le site web
que vous consultez
et il permet par exemple
de mémoriser vos mots de passe
pour vous connecter
sans avoir à les taper à chaque fois.
Les cookies reconnaissent également
vos préférences linguistiques.
Globalement, ils sont très utiles
pour améliorer la navigation sur Internet,
mais ils fournissent aussi
des informations
sur votre activité
pour vous faire des offres commerciales.
Par exemple, quelle page du site
vous avez regardé ?
Combien de temps vous y êtes restés ?
Au final, ils permettent de collecter
des données qui sont personnelles.
Mais certaines entreprises recueillent
des données beaucoup plus personnelles.
C'est le cas des données de santé.
Elles sont dites sensibles,
car elles fournissent des informations
très confidentielles.
Prendre un rendez-vous chez son médecin
en ligne, c'est déjà une donnée de santé.
Aujourd'hui, le transfert de ces données
est au cœur du système de soins.
Il facilite la mise en relation
entre le patient et le médecin.
L'objectif étant de mieux
gérer votre santé.
Et les exemples sont très concrets.
Plus besoin d'attendre que le cabinet
soit ouvert pour prendre rendez-vous.
Parmi les données collectées,
on trouve aussi les ordonnances délivrées
directement en ligne
et qui permettent les prescriptions
lors des téléconsultations.
Elles peuvent être envoyées directement
chez le pharmacien.
Au bout du compte,
c'est du temps de gagné pour le patient.
Et du temps, le praticien en gagne aussi.
Oui ? Allo? Ne quittez pas !
Vous avez de la fièvre ? Oh!
Fini ça ! Avec la prise de
rendez-vous en ligne,
Ils reçoivent concrètement
deux fois moins d'appels
et peuvent donc honorer
davantage de rendez-vous.
Les fameux lapins.
Mais non pas ceux-là !
Les rendez-vous que l'on oublie ou ceux
auxquels on arrive en retard
sont beaucoup moins nombreux 60%
en moins grâce aux rappels
par email ou par SMS.
En fait, c'est tout le cabinet
qui voit son activité améliorée.
Les personnes qui sont chargées du
secrétariat ont elles aussi plus de temps
pour se consacrer
à l'accueil des patients.
Un chirurgien dentiste,
par exemple, pourra davantage
s'appuyer sur l'aide de la personne
qui l'assiste durant des soins.
La collecte de données réduit
donc le temps consacré
aux tâches administratives
auxquelles le professionnel de santé
ne peut échapper.
C'est plus de confort pour lui
et il peut donc tout de suite
s'atteler à sa tâche première : soigner.
Enfin bon, ça en fait quand même
des informations de santé sur la Toile.
C'est vrai que derrière un simple
rendez-vous médical, il peut se cacher
un tas d'informations.
Le motif de la consultation, la maladie,
les risques de santé encourus...
On peut en apprendre beaucoup
sur le mode de vie des gens.
Oh là là, je préfère refermer
l'application tout de suite
et pas prendre de risque.
J'ai pas envie que tout le monde sache
que je suis myope comme une taupe.
Normalement, non.
Depuis 2018, en Europe,
les données personnelles,
dont les données de santé,
sont soumises à un règlement.
Le R.G.P.D. Le quoi ?
Le Règlement Général
sur la Protection des Données. Suivez-moi.
Et en matière de données de santé,
le RGPD est très strict.
La loi interdit formellement
de les revendre ou de les échanger
dans un but autre que strictement médical.
Il permet aussi à chacun de mieux
contrôler ses propres données.
Concrètement, on peut maintenant demander
à récupérer tout ce qui a été collecté.
Et si cela ne nous plaît pas,
on peut même aller jusqu'à supprimer
toutes ces données.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le droit à l'oubli.
C'est bien ça, mais avant de les
supprimer, quelqu'un peut il avoir accès
à ces données de santé ?
Personne ou presque
sur le site de prise de rendez-vous.
Les données fournies ne sont accessibles
qu'aux patients concernés
et à son médecin.
Personne ne peut y toucher,
car elles sont stockées dans des lieux
étroitement surveillés.
Les fameux Data Center ! De grands centres
d'hébergement de données.
Ah trop hâte de voir ça !
Allez, on y va. Là,
je crois que tu rêves un peu.
Impossible de se balader
au milieu des armoires de stockage.
J'ai essayé... Même
pour le tournage de cette vidéo,
l'adresse et l'accès d'un Data
Center de ce type m'ont été refusés.
Dommage! Ne sois pas triste.
Tu devrais plutôt être rassuré,
car ces centres abritent des millions
de données de santé de dizaines, voire
de centaines de milliers de patients.
Les miennes, les vôtres peut-être.
Elles sont stockées
dans de grands ordinateurs ultra protégés.
Ça ne vous amuserez pas
de savoir que l'on peut y pénétrer
comme dans un moulin.
Ce sont de véritables forteresses.
Ils sont surveillés physiquement,
mais ils doivent aussi respecter
des normes de protection françaises
et européennes et avoir reçu l'agrément
HDS : Hébergement de Données de Santé.
Un label qui garantit
que ces sociétés prennent au sérieux
la sécurité de l'information
et la protection des données personnelles
face aux pirates, notamment.
À l'abordage! Oui, je répète à l'abordage.
A mon avis, tu ne vas pas aller bien loin
comme ça, j'explique.
Il y a des antivirus et des pare-feux
partout pour éviter toute intrusion.
Les systèmes de protection
sont mis à jour régulièrement
et même si quelqu'un réussissait
à franchir les obstacles,
il ne serait pas au bout de ses peines.
Les données sont entièrement chiffrées,
traduites pour ne pas être lues.
Les lettres sont transformées en chiffres
une succession de 0 et de 1 généralement.
Et personne ne peut lire les données
sans avoir la clé de déchiffrement,
elle aussi stockée en lieu sûr.
C'est bien beau tout ça,
mais comment peut-on être sûr
que ces mesures sont respectées ?
Et qui vérifie? D'abord,
il faut savoir qu'en France,
chaque grande entreprise qui traite
des données de santé emploie une personne
déléguée au respect de la législation
sur la protection des données.
Il existe aussi, au niveau national,
un organisme qui fait office de gendarme,
la CNIL : la Commission Nationale
de l'Informatique et des Libertés.
Elle vérifie que les entreprises
respectent toutes les conditions
pour pouvoir utiliser
nos données en venant, par exemple,
visiter les centres d'hébergement.
La CNIL recueille également
les plaintes des utilisateurs.
En 2020, par exemple,
elle a reçu plus de 13 000 signalements,
toutes données confondues.
Chaque plainte est traitée
et si les règles sont enfreintes,
c'est la sanction assurée.
Tenez, l'année dernière, sur 247
contrôles, 11 amendes ont été délivrées
et ça peut coûter très cher.
Au total, plus de 138 millions d'euros.
Mais avant d'en arriver là,
voici quelques petits conseils
pour éviter les mauvaises surprises.
On vient de le voir.
Les données personnelles
nous facilitent la vie
et leurs usages sont bien réglementés.
Mais comme pour tout,
le risque zéro n'existe pas.
Si vous avez un doute
sur un site Internet, vérifiez bien
que la page de consentement aux cookies
s'ouvre dès votre arrivée.
Vous pouvez aussi lire
les règles de confidentialité pour savoir
exactement à quelles fins seront
utilisées vos données.
Et parfois, votre meilleur ami
peut vous jouer des tours s'il est utilisé
dans de mauvaises conditions.
Je parle de votre téléphone portable
ou de votre ordinateur.
Une simple connexion Internet
peut être un risque. Alors, afin
d'éviter de tenter les petits curieux,
mieux vaut donc essayer de se connecter
à des réseaux sécurisés
comme votre Wifi privé
et éviter le plus possible
les réseaux Wifi des lieux publics:
restaurants, hôtels ou transports.
Allez, un dernier conseil !
Même si les sites de santé
font le nécessaire
pour protéger nos données,
c'est aussi à nous de faire attention.
La vigilance individuelle
est la première des protections
et ce n'est pas forcément compliqué.
Complexifiez un maximum
les mots de passe de vos comptes,
évitez les dates de naissance
de vos enfants, le nom de votre chien
ou de votre poisson rouge.
C'est trop simple.
Ces mots de passe
peuvent rapidement être piratés.
Ah, je l'avais oublié, celui-ci.
J'ai rendez-vous demain
chez mon chirurgien dentiste.
Allez, je vous laisse,
je vais me brosser les dents.
Enfin bon, j'ai le temps quand même.